who's been like one of the celebrities
that you saw like singing along your
or posting your that you were
like whoa that's crazy like my song's
that big like that it reached this
person I ain't gonna lie I probably
don't even remember now because it's
just it's so many I'd be surprised about
all of them for real because I ain't
know the song was gonna even I'm like
yeah I really like this song
correct me if I'm on the cardi B say
something about it yeah everybody when I
say everybody everybody named mama
that's crazy it's just going all around
I feel like a pound town remix with
cardi B would be Monumental they were
saying that it's a lot of people that
was like it's a lot of people I want to
put on there I don't know how long what
do you want to put on it I don't know I
don't want to name drop nobody well you
know Anna Lee Choppa did two like
officially two remixes of me
outside I do like three or four I might
do something like that
or just put everybody on the same song
you could and just have it you know
Trina with Trina would be dope a lot of
people it's a lot of people I could
think of